radicalization and how it happens is now
once again
headline news in france now while most
questions are focusing on the impact of
social media
poverty and foreign influence the
country's interior minister
has come up with this suggestion as one
root
of the problem it has always shocked me
to go into a supermarket
and see that when entering there would
be one type of ethnic food selection
here
and another one next to it domino went
on to say
this is how communal terrorism begins
it's a term
that loosely translates as identity and
it's also used to describe those
who don't comply or respect the idea of
secularism here in france
that's the separation of religion and
state and even though the interior
minister says
he doesn't want to forbid ethnic food
isles in supermarkets
his comments have caused a stir with
many mocking him
[Music]
domino also thinks it's up to big
business owners to do
their bit in fighting separatism so
what about restaurants streets like this
one here in paris offer a plethora of
selection from
turkish to chinese italian to indian
cuisine
are they two along with supermarket
isles setting people on the path to
become
bad french citizens
i think it's important to respect
diversity and that should be also be
reflected in supermarkets
there should be everything for everyone
including in france
if there is a demand for something it
should be there
that's one of the things that's so great
about france is that we do have people
from lots of different countries
i mean i'm american and i've lived in
france for about five years
i don't really think for me it's really
super normal if i go in a
supermarket and see the i don't really
think about that so i don't really see
the harm behind it
despite the pushback the interior
minister says he doesn't want to forbid
ethnic food aisles in supermarkets but
he does think it's up to big business
owners to do
their bit in fighting separatism
some though do you think dominance
comments have
merit and should be considered
the minister is right a kosher or halal
food isle is the beginning of
communitarianism
kosher or halal food should be available
in the general isles
along with other food but having a
dedicated aisle is the beginning of
communitarianism
because we know that everyone who goes
there is muslim or jewish
the interior minister says he doesn't
have one word to take back
but given that perhaps his badly phrased
thoughts have been made
in the aftermath of that brutal terror
attack
on french teacher samuel petty and while
a terror trial is underway over the 2015
attack on a kosher supermarket
many are incensed dominar it seems is
not so much
cooking up a storm with his words but
wading into some
very hot water charlotte dubinsky
rt paris
you